peu à tout à l'heure le festival
d'avignon maintenant jeanne moreau
retourne à ses premières amours dans la
cour du palais des papes à l'âge où
autrefois le prince de hombourg en
compagnie de gérard philipe aujourd'hui
la voilà dans la célestine mise en scène
par antoine vitez et patrick voix et qui
rit et sont allés à la rencontre de ceux
qui vont à coup sûr créer l'événement
cette année en abyme avignon en fièvre
comme chaque année ils sont venus ils
sont tous là comédien saltimbanques star
touristes peau mais tous ont envahi la
ville pour le versant le rythme de vie
des habitants et transformant le paysage
en une gigantesque foire au théâtre plus
de 400 spectacles
c'est le plus grand festival européen de
théâtre et c'est pour bientôt
la com en prenant demain cette année le
festival sur 10 mois un prénom célestine
rôle titre de la pièce de fernando
terreau iasc joue jeanne moreau pour ces
retrouvailles en avignon
célestine sépare les uns ni les autres
qui sa toile d'un personnage à l'autre
avec la précision et la cruauté d'une
araignée s'engage pleinement dans le
rôle qu'elles jouent pas ce que l'euro
les plus plus qu'un rôle le rôle
d'ailleurs ce rôle de célestine
évidemment représente représente aussi
toute l'histoire des femmes une certaine
façon et comme sa carrière sera
constituée à représenter l'histoire
d'une femme
l'histoire des femmes les rames il me
semble qu'il ya quelque chose
comme la saône ans l'analogie rentrer
ce rôle là où ils jouent toutes les
histoires en avignon jeanne moreau a
changé de partenaire le bot lambert
wilson a remplacé le veau gérard philipe
mais son jeu est identique
elle donne tout toujours venu cima
conjuration les toits et à plus du
double est sacrifié pour ressusciter
habillement